suspended animation the sci-fi flick
2001 a Space Odyssey imagined it as
humans hibernating in pods
[Music]
in the real world a scrappy fish
undergoes it or something like it to
survive dried-up ponds the African
turquoise Killa fish jolts to light
following a phase called diapause it's a
state of suspended development that
helps organisms survive extreme
environments diapause exists among other
vertebrates such as roe deer bears and
even lab mice and in his led scientists
to wonder do organisms aged at all
during the process new research into
African Killa fish has shown that its
period of diapause during embryo
development has no negative effects on
the lifespan of a fully developed adult
turns out the African Killa fish is a
perfect candidate to help answer the
diapause lifespan conundrum it's short
life span of four to six months
coincides with the wet seasons in
countries like Mozambique and Zimbabwe
so the African Killa fish species has
evolved to have its embryos entered
diapause so that they survive the
extreme dryness that follows these rainy
periods
unlike in mammals Killa fish embryos
grow outside of the animal's body which
makes them easier to experiment on for
their experiment scientists established
two groups one that hatched without
entering diapause and one that hatched
after experiencing five months diapause
surprisingly after hatching both groups
live roughly the same length of time
which led the researchers to conclude
that diapause had little to no
deleterious effects past research
discovered that diapause delayed aging
with invertebrates such as insects and
the worm C elegans
but this African killer fish research is
unique since the killer fish is a
vertebrate after observing how diapause
occurs naturally in Killa fish the
researchers went the extra mile they
investigated how the perturbation of
specific genes might affect the embryos
during diapause they found that knocking
out a gene called CB x7
caused embryos to fail to maintain
diapause highlighting the importance of
specific genes in maintaining the
suspended state the researchers believe
these findings could help discover
general mechanisms that preserve cells
such as stem cells for long periods of
time this could also inform strategies
to combat aging and age-related diseases
in other words studying how the African
Killa fish pauses its clock during
development to perhaps identify ways to
adjust the aging clock in other species
including humans
[Music]